je perds ce soit
[Musique]
ce soir c'est le titre de cette chanson
composée et interprétée par la jeune
artiste rome s'est elle a 25 ans cette
versailles et se produit toutes les deux
semaines au café de la pêche à
versailles elle a fait ses études au
conservatoire de musique de la ville
j'ai commencé avec la flûte à bec qui a
été mon premier instrument et ensuite je
me suis un autodidacte je me suis
intéressé au piano et à la guitare
et j'ai fait un an de saxophone au
conservatoire devient où les roms s'est
elle a commencé à écrire et composer des
chansons à 14 ans en avril dernier elle
sort son premier ep intitulé aperçu je
voulais vraiment faire de la musique ma
vie et on travaille enfin être vraiment
dedans donc j'ai décidé de faire de paix
pour montrer un peu ce que je pouvais
faire penser vraiment une palette de
cinq titres différents qui ont été
écrits sur six en quoi dans les rues je
crois que je suis père du petit garçon
et moi l'artiste versailles et s'est
tourné vers la pop et la variété
française avec quelques accords jazz qui
raconte
nous plaît vécu qu'on a entre 14 et 20
ans à peu près les sentiments qu'on peut
avoir les difficultés qu'on rencontre
les concepts cinq titres qui parlent de
son vécu le clip de la chanson sublime
et sort dans quelques semaines si vous
aimer cette musique qui parle vraiment
de
de tout ce qu'on a autour de nous qui
est des conditions des conditionnements
qu'on a on nous oblige à avoir et qui
peuvent nous mettre certains complexes
de certains qui nous empêche de sentir
pas bien avec nous mêmes et qu'ils vont
mettre des stops sur ce qu'on voudrait
être en 2020 de robe celle des projets
plein la tête avec notamment la sortie
de son deuxième ep